hi nice to meet you good afternoon my
name is Arthur I work for Cartoon
Network I'm the regional senior digital
manager that's a fancy thing to say but
I basically work on the content team in
Cartoon Network basically creating
content for digital I'm a gamer I'm a
designer I graduated in design I am a
youtuber as well my channel has an
impressive number of 12 followers 12
subscribers so that's fancy for me and
just to talk a little bit of what we do
and what is Cartoon Network so this is
Cartoon Network we're we are not a TV
channel we're strong brand and we are
working with a lot of different
platforms we have the TV channel the TV
channel has been existing for more than
20 years so this is the number one thing
that we do we are number one in ratings
with kids and this is important for us
we do work a lot with site games
applications digital social media so
this is huge for us this has been huge
for more than 15 years the Cartoon
Network's website when I was a kid like
2530 years ago I used to enter not 30
maybe a little bit less but I used to
enter on the Cartoon Network website and
I used to play games we started building
games from at least when I was growing
up I was playing already the Cartoon
Network game so this was really
important for us from the beginning and
we do have also a strong licensing and
live events and other stuff that we do
on Cartoon Network as well so this is a
little bit of who we are and what we do
so this I'm going to talk about some of
the learnings of like building apps and
games from from the past five or six
years so this is something of the of
what we came across and some of the
stuff that we we realized was important
and I want to point out like in a top 10
list of things that we we learn by
developing or games in our apps and we
learn from our audience and we learn
from our fan base and this is the most
important thing that you you need to
understand whenever you're talking about
user acquisition or user engagement the
first thing that you need to do is
actually listening to your audience and
understanding what
you're asking and how they are West they
are asking so first of all I cannot
express the importance of your content
I mean content is the number one thing
you have to look at whenever you're
you're developing an idea creating an
idea developing a game you should
consider your content and how you're
working with the content I mean the
gameplay is key I mean if you're
developing a game please take a look at
a game play how do you how how does it
work how kids play with the gameplay
this is really important and this
actually will will show up in the later
stage if you don't prepare your your
gameplay to be fun in the beginning and
then stage it won't work so this is
specifically true cartoon I mean our IPS
they are everywhere they are on games
they are on TV they are on licensing
they are on live events so this is how
we do we we tend to work on a big bigger
solid storytelling approach so what
happened with this is that gaming is a
part of that IP of that intellectual
property so we try to expand the
storytelling approach so you will learn
some key things from the game playing
the game and watching the the series you
learn some new things and this is
something that actually changed within
Cartoon Network usually digital was
separated for from from from content so
the studios in LA that develop all all
of our shows they were separated from
digital so what happened is that we
simply merge together
so right now digital is part of content
and digital is singing as content so we
work closely together with the studios
to actually create and develop games and
create idea and the storytelling is a
big part of this so a lot of our games
are actually being being worked by the
same script writers that work with the
TV show so in this way you are sure that
you were working on something that makes
sense for the audience and it connects
with your brand ID so this is really
important again
content is also understanding what your
kids like so look at the kids look at
what they watch what they play
understand what they consume so you can
apply and learn from that whenever
you're producing any of your apps and
and whenever you're working with content
so if you're working on on a title
that's has human much text maybe that's
not something that I younger kid would
like maybe you need to understand how
they're consuming that before planning
that into your game so you're not
cutting surprise we don't want to have
like a huge story because we know that
gameplay is more important so this is
also important to evaluate whenever
you're creating your game so please
always check on what kids are doing so
this is an example that I like to point
out this is Steven attack delight this
is a this is actually an app that was
released in 2015 this was an app that it
was it is one of our greatest apps we
worked with the show crew to develop the
app not only this story was created by
the show team they did the same script
writers but the full aspect of the of
the app was developed by the day our
team from the studios in LA so what you
were doing was like okay let's let's
take a look to be sure that this this
this app and this game communicates to
what Steven truly is and whenever this
happens it's really fun to to just go
through the comments on this tour and
just realize that people are really
commenting like hey this this app feels
like a an episode of the show and this
is amazing for us and this is part of
like working together and this is the
results that we have so this is
something that it's really important
like content wise the second thing that
I would say that it's really important
and sometimes I feel like in the past
maybe we forgot sometimes but you're
working with kids so you need to think
as a parent and thinking as a kid at the
same time so you cannot propose an app
that has something that a parent might
not like so for instance at one point we
already oh it would be nice to have more
social appeal let's let's place Facebook
okk like a facebook plugin so people can
share the app on Facebook but when when
you start to think on that it's it's
really delicate the way that you need to
work with your content so you're not
pushing kids to someplace that they are
not supposed to be or pushing kids to a
place that parents wouldn't like that
that kid should be sometimes the kids
are there they we see some researching
and kids are saying no and they're my
parent doesn't know I'm accessing
Facebook I have an account but what
happens is that they're going against
their parents and we need you think with
the parents head I mean if the parents
doesn't like it we shouldn't do it as
well so we need to come up with a good
balance and understand what we can do
and what we can offer so we are not
delivering something that's not harmful
for for either the kid or the parents
and that's why this is a strong point
because I think sometimes we completely
forget about this I mean we're working
with kids so how how should you play how
should you place your in-app purchase
content I mean again you're working with
kids
so sometimes we receive some news like a
key the expand spends like I don't know
five thousand dollars on on an app so
that's not really good so you have to
really balance and again think as a
parent think as a kid and see how you're
demonstrating that inside your game so
and I can't I can't go on I mean there's
like for instance if you're launching
your game on us you have like Coppa
which is like legal that that has some
restrictions with kids and how how you
collect information from kids so this is
really sensitive information that you
need to consider whenever you're you're
producing an app for for a kid so number
three I mean how does your game stand
out I mean looking at it at the the App
Store looking at all the games looking
at with the games that are training app
how you're separating your games from
what is already launched we in cartoon
we never simply okay flappy birds is
okay doing your amazing let's just
create a flappy birds with a cartoon
character that's not how we play it
that's not how how we sell our games and
that's not how we envision the creation
of content and game
so what we we usually do is actually
thinking about it a little bit more okay
so flappy birds is something that works
how can we we learn from that what are
the things that kids are addicted to how
can we evolve that and add a new thing
inside of our game so how can we
innovate on something that it was
already launched so this is number three
because it's part of this the Cartoon
Network DNA which is innovation I mean
if you if you take a little bit from the
previous talk I mean we were learning
about kids curiosity so this is
important for us as well which is
actually bringing some new stuff so that
the kid can actually have something new
to iterate and to learn from so it's not
simply a copy from an hour game so this
is this is another thing that is really
important and we learn a lot from this
is that iteration I mean once you have a
game project from the day one show I
don't know day five day 10 day 100 the
game skip keeps on changing I mean you
learn a lot from playtesting so you play
tasks with a kid and you simply
understand it's something that you
imagine like oh this is just like a side
part of the app it suddenly that that's
the thing that you need to focus your
efforts on because this is the thing
that it's it's playing the most and kids
are enjoying the most so your game
constantly changed and the project will
will never be the same because it keeps
on evolving and keeps on evolving and
changing so this is an example that we
do as well this is Adventure Time game
wizard this is a game that we released
in 2013 if I'm not mistaken and this
evolved involved innovation in so many
ways I mean it was like a platformer
think on a Mario but the big change this
game is that you could actually create
your own game on paper so you could draw
your levels and you could scan your
levels through the cell phone and that
level would be written by the app and
you could play the game on on your own
level and kids could create a vast
majority of levels you could play with
with other levels created by other kids
and the way that you created the level
as well was like really simple you
didn't have to draw a lot but the app
under stood like signal so if you--if
you'll design like a plus sign on a
sheet of paper it would understand like
okay this plus sign is a coin so it
would read that and it would throw that
in in the in the app so for us this is
something that was like really cool
because it was actually uniting
something again when I when I was a kid
I was I used to love to do that which
was basically drawing and we are trying
to unite something that kids like to do
live and something that they like to do
on digital so this is something that was
really important for us and it had like
a huge UGC opportunity so for us this
was really cool as well because you
could share what we were doing it's not
a social media but inside the app you
could actually see that other people
were playing you could like other people
levels so this was good as well kids
love to play and like stuff so this for
us he enabled other other things that
were really positive for us as well
number four
localization localization working with
kids it's a must a must I mean this we
we learned this the hard way sometimes
we we do develop all the apps generated
by cartoon deer worked like globally so
we release an app in every single region
like Latin we work in the US MEA which
is Europe and Asia so for us what we
understand from this is that whenever we
we were like okay let's let's try to
launch this this game in English you
know like it's a simple game maybe it
won't damage a lot but what what we
learned from this whenever we launched a
game in English for it might be like
really little text but that little text
makes the difference and people would
complain like hey this game is not in my
language this game is not in Portuguese
this game is not in Chinese this game is
not in Japanese so for us localization
is really important because kids like
that and the parents like that and not
only if you think on even going back
like on on TV trends you might hear in
Brazil this is like really common so you
might think like most of the movie
channels at one point they were all
simply dubbing all their movies so this
is a trend not only for kids this is a
trend
for for adults as well everyone likes to
read and they feel comfortable to hear
in their original language so this is a
trend and whenever people ask me like oh
no but how come the TV channel change
from from English subtitles and to your
Portuguese this is crazy I love English
but whenever you look at the ratings the
ratings actually improved EFT after we
did that and the same applies show true
apps and the same applies to everything
that we do in digital so whenever we we
work with the local language we get much
more better results so this is this is a
important thing to understand and right
now this is a huge gaming market trend I
mean whenever you see any game right now
they are being translated if you think
on on the big titles on a PlayStation
Store for instance they are being
translated to Portuguese they have
Portuguese voiceover so this is really
important for us so an example was card
Wars car Wars was a huge help with I
mean it's one of our biggest apps so it
had a lot of text I mean it was massive
text I mean finger on a card game with
more than I don't know what a thousand
cards so at one point we released a
single patch with new cards that didn't
had like all the translations on the
cards and and we were like on the
comments everywhere what happened
the app is bugged it's showing me
English tag so we went back and we we
saw that some some cards were English
and we translated it and that made a
difference people were like ah now now
they heard us now it's in Portuguese now
it's okay so this is something that's
that's really really important to
understand and yes it does make a
difference
so you have to understand the game
lifecycle as well it's not like okay
they wanna launch the app okay I'm done
I'm already released it wolf I can just
rest and move on to the next thing I'm
going to do that's that's not how we see
your apps I mean we see your apps as
constantly evolving so what happens on
day one that's day one I mean you you
had all the development of that dead yep
but they one is the one for the
lifecycle of the app so you need to to
look at the app and you need to evolve
the app so okay I see like
30 days the comments are that this thing
is broken okay let's fix it all people
are saying the game is too short okay
let's change it and add new levels so
you have to understand that this is
important and this will help push your
app up so you cannot miss this what we
do as well and what is really important
is is also adding like relevant content
from different seasons so let's say
right now it's Halloween
okay let's produce a special package for
Halloween with special Halloween content
so kids can have something that they
relate there that is happening with
their life at that same time so
Halloween is a topic for them I'm sure
that if we have Halloween costumes
inside add and add a kid will love to
see that and to have that so this is
really important for us and you can
think on any different like in in Brazil
you can think like okay Carnaval is
something really important okay maybe we
should do and we could do and and and
development of I don't know like some
carnival team stuff for your app and
that will show the difference and that
will be pushed up again so that's really
important like the app app icon this is
something that we we always talk I mean
I was like in this morning people were
talking the importance of the app pack
icon and and testing it and
understanding it and looking at our
audience and changing it and that goes
through iteration and learn from what
your you're getting and also the app
icon so if you're having a Halloween
maybe you can change your app icon show
a pumpkin or something that has to do
with Halloween so the kids can nurse and
okay this is Halloween I'm leaving
Halloween so this is cool for me so here
is another example two new Titans is a
game that goes really into the DA
Cartoon Network DNA it makes a lot of
fun off of these kind of games they're
like Disney infinity you know like live
toys and this is a game that mix that
with Pokemon and we are just making a
huge fun out of this so what we did with
with with this app is actually you had a
lot of of different figurines to collect
and this is one of our apps that is to
training right now we launched for more
than then six months and it's still
performing really good for us
and and on Halloween for instance we
released neo collectibles that had to do
with Halloween the game had Halloween
all around it so for us it was like a
nice update it had all to do with what
was happening at the time we also
updated I mean we had a we had the the
neo not Batman movie but they moved the
new Batman movie I don't know the naming
the suicide spot so for us I mean there
were there were characters in the movie
that we could include it was around the
same time so we included that so Harley
Quinn was there so I mean we also looked
at what up what was happening in a
stronger angle and for us this matched
perfectly with what was happening
outside and for us this also showed the
results number six maintain and nurture
your fan base I mean again this is
something that it's it's really I can
say on our end it's like a huge work but
you need to constantly look at what
people are saying about your app you
have to answer to comments on the store
this morning
Google was also saying the benefits that
you have whenever you're addressing to
comments oh and reveal so people
reviewing your app and you're constantly
checking and you're being sure that okay
someone reported a bug I'm being sure
that I'll fix it I'll see if it's true
or not and you can also answer and you
should always answer the users so so you
you get a feedback and that should drive
the ratings of your store higher up and
this will get you better results in the
end so social media again it's not
something that we push for it but social
media sometimes we search for it so even
though we are not like 100% giving away
our stuff on social media we are really
into social media just to see like what
are the trends what people are saying
we're looking at PR we are looking at
what the media is saying about our game
we're looking at youtubers sometimes we
get insights from youtubers that are
just commenting on our game and they're
coming in like hey I like this I don't
like this we are reading through the
comments and seeing the comments and
what people are saying about it so all
of these empowers our understanding of
our our fan
and what they want and this also
empowers us sometimes with with trends
and stuff that sometimes we didn't even
imagine but someone might say like hey I
really love this game imagine a version
to where you added this this and that
so we can read some trends and we can
translate us these trends later on to
other different games or just true true
for us who evolve on on something so
again this is really really really
important and and I cannot stress the
importance of this slide and here's an
example this was actually not an app but
this was more to promote a Powerpuff
Girls we were relaunching the Powerpuff
Girls this year and it was important for
us to talk about it and and and I mean
we have a huge fan base that are like
older people because Powerpuff Girls is
more than 20 years so we wanted to
communicate with with an older audience
that loved the show we wanted to let
them know like hey Powerpuff Girls is
back so what we produced and we had an
app a paid app for the Powerpuff Girls
and what we did with this was like a way
it was like a web application that you
could access through your mobiles mobile
phone or through the site and it was a
way to spread out a word like hey the
Powerpuff Girls are back they have a new
new look so it was like more of a
marketing tool but for us it was like
really impressive like the day when we
launched this we didn't expect the
success that he was I mean a lot of PR
over this we did have enabled a social
media sharing it was not the app it was
something outside the app but for us
what it was good either way so in this
you had like if you're over 13 you could
publish this on Facebook if you're a
younger than 13 you could save to your
desktop or something saved your computer
so again this is stuff that kids can
manage true okay say I'm older but
either way it's it's a way that parents
like feel safe oh no cartoon is looking
at my kids they are not publishing
something that I don't want to say and
again this
was everywhere everyone started
publishing the the avatars they changed
on Facebook it was everywhere so for us
this was an initiative that helped
placing the Powerpuff Girls brand in the
in the consumers mind and for us this
was this was really important at the
time analytics key again once you
release your game take a look at
analytics take a look and at what is
happening on your game so let's say like
you have a long tutorial on the game and
suddenly you see an illegal are just
dropping your game from from the five
seconds to start like you you're having
a lot of of give ups on your game so
maybe maybe you you should you should
look at it and and change maybe kids
doesn't want a tutorial maybe it can be
skippable sometimes we realize like you
place a skip button and it's not a big
enough sometimes small people don't
don't understand so even and this is not
for kids only but you should consider
adults as well sometimes we are like oh
no but come on this is so this is so
clear how come the user is not
understanding it but believe me the
users don't understand a lot of the
times so try to change your app and that
goes with what I said before which is
like actually iteration which is
actually changing your app learning with
your app and looking at the numbers and
see what is happening look if you change
something and suddenly the numbers go
down maybe okay that that's not a good
move maybe we should re-evaluate and
change it again so this is something
that you you need to measure your app
from from every single step and just
keep looking at the analytics and see
what is happening and see how you can
improve based on hard data and not based
on only on user feedback that's
something but this is this is going to
empower your your user feedback so you
see if you see analytics going bad in
some place and if you see your users are
complaining the same place okay so you
have two things to tackle at once so
this is an important thing to to notice
yeah here is about CEO so I think I've
run out of time right
speak a lot right yes yes I'll just move
on fast so co-op optimized you're a
parade I mean make sure that it's
searchable make sure that you're having
the right tax on it make sure that
you're addressing the right words to
make it find a bow I mean in the end
everyone is is on searching engines 9
marketing strategy I mean if you don't
have a marketing strategy thinkin about
how to make partners if you don't have
money try to partner up with with with
other other people and just understand
how how you can empower your marketing
we do a lot of marketing we are
constantly looking at what our people
are doing how they are marketing your
apps and we are constantly learning from
that as well and we apply that to our
apps here is an example that for us as a
TV channel and as a big media company we
are we are lucky that we have the
channels and we can promote everything
that we do on the TV channel and as
being number one in around the region
this really helps us to push everything
that we produce so this really helped us
again number 10 and this is it and then
public relations I mean think on public
relations as something more expanded so
not only look for I would say the
traditional one like talking with the
press but think that public relations
right now is way bigger than that I mean
think on YouTube YouTube right now you
have so many youtubers that are creating
just a preview so they're sometimes as
big or even bigger than a traditional
media press oh you should go to these
guys and talk with them and try to start
a relationship with them somehow give
them your app so they can test it if
they like it or not or something like
that so this is something that might be
really good for for your app and that's
it I'm sorry I ran out of time thank you
very much I hope you enjoyed it thank
you